it's popping rockstars my name is mt and
congratulations everybody
sylvie just decapitated a lizardman
keeper of the time
and saved the entire multiverse from
cosmic fascism hooray
if only it were that easy because
spoiler alert much like the time travel
of back to the future
the time keepers are a bunch of [ __ ]
a bunch of [ __ ] which of course has
all of us loki loving nerds on
disneyplus.com
dazed and confused for a number of good
reasons but outside of the obvious big
questions like who created the tva and
the timekeepers in the first place one
of the more intriguing questions for me
personally
is why did the puppet master behind the
timekeepers
bring loki and sylvie in front of their
fake android presence
in the first place i mean loki even
asked this question to their ugly lizard
faces in episode 4
like why was that something that needed
to be done i mean we already know that
they're not gonna listen to these loki's
because their entire judicial system is
a sham
why not just prune these two
troublemaking logi as soon as they're
found
well i think the answer to this lies in
both previous episodes of loki as well
as the marvel comics so buckle up gang
because we're about to hop onto the jet
ski of speculation
i don't know what that means jet skis
don't have seat belts
i should go outside more i think the
simple answered as to why the time
keeper puppet master wanted
loki and sylvie to see these robotic
representations of the timekeepers
is because they wanted loki and silvie
to believe
in the grand tva lie it's all about the
power of belief and this ties back to
the conversation between moby's and loki
in episode 2 of the series you know when
loki is challenging moby is his belief
in the tva and mobius hits him with the
reverse uno
by saying that the tba is just as
miraculously real as loki in the entire
existence of the mythical gods and
enemies of asgard
mainly because as mobius says and it's
real because i believe it's real
this moment right here is a moment that
i am absolutely confident will be
referenced again because this
conversation is massive foreshadowing to
exactly how the all-powerful
tva will probably be taken down by the
end of the series
and why do i say this easy because of a
little something that i like to call
um loki agent of asgard number 17
now in this issue we find loki
confronting the super ultra secret
mythical gods worshiped by the asgardian
gods
known as those who sit above in shadow
in their native dimension outside of the
marvel universe
and these are the gods that the
asgardians worshiped as the beings that
created all of them
and we learned from the ragnarok story
from the thor disassembled comics that
those who sit above in shadow
feed off of the life force energy of all
the dead asgardians
after the ragnarok event and that they
have been purposely looping the
asgardians in a wheel of fate that ends
in these ragnaroks so they can feed on
the asgardian life forces
pretty much forever those who sit above
in shadow are straight up one of the
most powerful forces
in the entire marvel hierarchy and yet
in this issue loki sends these
all-powerful entities
sprinting for the nearest exit sign with
just his words
and how did yoton times tiniest frost
giant do this by challenging their
entire existences
to their faces because comic loki was
like wait a minute if we the asgardian
gods
only exists because humanity believes
that we are real and the asgardians
worship you guys
as the guys that created them and
believe that you are real
then did you guys create us or did we
create to which those who sit above and
shadow replied
la la la la la we can't hear you you
have a nice day blah blah blah
bye mainly because in that scenario loki
was the last asgardian left so their
entire existence
sort of relied on whatever loki believed
i believe that this moment
from loki agents of asgard number 17 has
informed the entire existence of the tva
in this loki series with whoever is
actually in charge of the tva relying on
the belief of their variant workforce
to sustain them but before i continue i
just want to give a huge thank you to
skillshare for sponsoring this video
skillshare is an online learning
community with
thousands of inspiring classes for
curious creative folks and skillshare
allows you to explore new skills
deepen existing passions and get lost in
creativity skillshare offers classes
designed for real life and you can learn
and grow with short classes that fit any
schedule and each class is a combination
of video lessons
and a class project and they have
classes and topics that new rockstars
fans would really enjoy
like animation film music and
freelancing one of the classes that
really interests me
is a class called presentation design
for smart people by
mj trong an industrial engineer at the
mayer innovation factory i sometimes
have to give presentations for work
and over the last year i ended up doing
some fun ones remotely for friends so
some expert advice on how to make them
more interesting
and effective sounds really cool to me
it's curated specifically for learning
meaning that there are no ads and
they're always launching new
premium classes so that you can stay
focused and follow wherever your
creativity takes
you the first 1 000 of our subscribers
to click the link in the description
will get one
free month trial of skillshare so that
you can start exploring your creativity
today but anyways this is because like
in the comics there is immense power
within the mind of the evolved
beings of the mcu and like the ancient
one notes in doctor strange 1
your mind can create your reality but do
you know where
this fact is especially true a little
place called
the quantum realm now there is a common
loki theory on the internet that states
that the entire tva
exists within the quantum realm and if
this is indeed the case then the human
mind has
even more power here than anywhere else
because think back to the time when hank
pym pulled up honey i shrunk the kids
and myself to save you because
tinder is a terrible place for janet van
dyne and ant-man and the boss
seemingly as a protection mechanism hank
mentally creates
a physical replica of his old house all
around him like
that house was actually physically there
with him within the quantum realm
because you can actually see
the quantum realm doing its thing in the
windows in the background
that is until janet van dyne heals
hank's mind with her magic quantum
powers by you know touching his brain
touching his temples and being like
baby it's okay your wife's here i'm
right here boo boo
i'm right here i don't know why i'm
rubbing my own temples it's because i'm
so alone
and when she did that the house went
away so if the tva is composed of a
bunch of variant minds within the
quantum realm
then whoever is truly behind all of this
could be using these minds to project
the entire tva
itself hell the human mind in the
quantum realm even allowed janet van
dyne to possess scott lang
for a good amount of time this is why
renslayer immediately puts a hit out on
hunter b15
claiming that she was compromised after
talking to sylvie it's because
rentslayer knows that if one tva agent
knows the truth of who they are
soon everybody in the tva will know the
truth and you can't have a time variance
authority if your variants don't believe
or respect your authority respect my
authority
this is why whoever created the
timekeeper androids wanted loki and
sylvie to see them because they wanted
these two rebels to believe in the lie
of their power
because doing so would give them even
more power because as we found out after
loki is pruned you don't die when you're
pruned like you get sent
somewhere else somewhere else that i
believe to be the land of limbo
in the comics limbo is a pocket
dimension outside of time and space
where everything that ever was and ever
will be
sort of exists all at once in a singular
moment
this is probably why we see mobius
whipping that thing towards a great
sphinx in a tv spot for dizzy plus all
the way back in may that sphinx seems
mighty out of place if you ask me
and since we already see mobius getting
pruned chances are he's probably landed
in limbo with the rest of everyone
that's ever been pruned or at the very
least with the rest of all these loki's
that we see at the end of episode four
because i believe mobius is a loki but
we're not gonna get into that right now
by having this pocket dimension limbo
prison whoever created the keepers could
keep all of these chaotic loki into one
boring messed up place where they live
out their immortal lives believing in
the timekeeper's authority because
they're the ones who set them there in
the first place
and that is what i like to call
controlled chaos but that's basically it
i believe that the tva
exists because everybody at the tva
believes it exists it's all about the
belief of the mind and the mind has a
lot of power and i strongly believe that
we're going to learn more about the mind
as phase 4 goes on especially
with doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness ant-man and the wasp
and the eternals as they are set to
introduce the concept of the unimide
but what do you guys think do you
believe in my theory of belief and do
you think that these loki's could
actually be in limbo talk nerdy to me
below my nerd babies but thank you guys
so much for watching this video you can
follow me at mastertainment if you want
to see me tweet some weird [ __ ] but most
importantly please follow the new
rockstars wherever we are especially on
youtube and when you do
make sure you hit that notification bell
so you can get notifications whenever we
upload a new video
also please support us at
newrockstarsmerch.com because we have
awesome shirts like this tv
shirt that i love so go to new
rockstarsmerch.com and make sure you get
that latest obsession shirt because it's
not going to be around forever
anyway thank you guys so much for
watching stay safe i love you guys and
i'll see you guys next time
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you